welcome to this video playing mr.
serious I'm hungry yeah he recently beat
me in a Spanish that was a pretty bad
loss so I'm trying a different line now
yeah that's an interesting variation
sometimes caught like a smaller offline
as kasparov has played this quite a bit
and like around two thousand ya mean one
in the final years of his career so I
decide massive it without coming I guess
never saw this idea maybe you can go
nitrogen 60 actually this one okay hmm
yeah I guess I have to I really have to
if I go Quincy to g6 it's a really
awkward pin
let's do this I don't think yeah I think
he had to do that it's not a very happy
move to make Queenie seven Queens 726
something like that I wouldn't ever can
just push a 3 enter and you for here
let's do that taking all your three
years not not on now if for was my DM
you for
g5 probably hmm not sure maybe i can say
i should prepare it yeah going all the
way back on to g3 yes to look at to do
something about a five anyway how is he
keeping it actually he isn't so let's
grab
just couldn't be three or something I
mean with the center I don't really see
him getting enough counterplay doing for
Queen before I could have done that may
be immediately yeah okay
teams takes pawn teams 94 must be okay
Oh b5 actually sorry b5 is much stronger
and then we can go here
yeah that looks good
got a good porn and the night is not a
bad piece that at all and how to do it
some something with e4 and e5 won't be
good you can also be ready for each for
its it's not bad sometimes I'll just
play to automatic our sister threatens
96 but that didn't really didn't really
do much so how to do this here
I will coming to the five maybe and
let's go here for fo fo n t5 going to
push them away whether you form no I'm
not okay this is running into Bishop b3
well I really playing this badly him mmm
so now okay one I guess check some what
about t5 putting this into a pin
so good
and drew a time morning Luke a force
also what's so possible let's let's do
it check check check no back here that
was my idea checking in from the back
quite sure why I actually gave up that
porn check check check I see clear way
forward you really don't look 25 check
probably not a great idea of eight
seconds what am I doing here check check
check check check check game draw oh wow
ah i'm not i'm not winning this position
when because i'm playing badly right how
about this it's really a bit of a shame
it wasn't it was pretty ok we have
really played it ok TI probably made too
many second-rate moves check and it
still should win even though i gave him
far more general check up check yeah
should have related here tempo something
like that wins a lever probably a couple
of ways to win this end game that
opening line scale interesting at early
90 296 I think that there is actually
something like that but i really wonder
yeah maybe he could have played g5 here
that was kind of a gamble but i thought
it's maybe worth trying something like
this I can go knight c6 back I know well
I probably can it's a very very weird
position but maybe you should have
should have done that I mean here I
think I really should be should be
somewhat better this even the direct
before was interesting but he's got g5
and couldn't really yeah I didn't really
could really establish how how good this
is it was ok the way I went way it went
yeah I computer wants to go to f2 even
maybe yeah maybe this is better I mean
I'll getting I'm getting this and
keeping this on the night doesn't have a
good outpost it was probably even
stronger then then what I played ok well
thanks for watching